هكذا صار حاله يخيم على شكله الاسى
لم يتوقع الحشر في الدين الشاب العشريني
ان ينتهي طموحه بمثل صدمه كهذه
فبعد ان سعى لتحقيق احلامه بدراسه
الماجستير في احدى الجامعات الامريكيه
بات الان يواجه احدى ماسي الحرب وصدماتها
القاسيه في السودان وقدمت
في السفاره يوم اثنين اربعه فالدون
الابوينت يوم 11/4
وفعلا مشيت الانترفيو والحمد لله كانت
الفيزا
وبعد ما رجعتها تابعته في السيستم بتاعهم
بعد يوم كانت الفيزا يشوت يعني اتطبعت في
الجواز وكان المفروض استلم الجواز مطبوع
فيه الفيزا يوم 16/4 او يوم 18/4
لم يقف عاجزا عند ذلك بل بذل كل ما في
وسعه لايجاد حل ما ثاني حاولت تراسل معه
منشوف
اي اجراء ممكن
يطلعنا من البلد فبيجي معي عندنا لا عندنا
البرد وفي نفس الوقت ما يعني زول يتفاجئ
صراحه اتصدم انه راح يقدر يبدا دراسته في
الوقت المحدد ولا حيقدر يطلع من البلد
بعده
للاسف تدمر لم يكن وحده من تضرر من هذا
الاجراء اذ نشرت نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
مقالا مفصلا يضم اخرين
تمزقت احلام الكثيرين هنا بسبب اتلاف
السفاره الامريكيه ما بداخلها من جوازات
قبيل عمليه الاجلاء وهو بروتوكول شاركته
سفارات اوروبيه اخرى
واضعه من شملهم ذلك في قدر بروتوكول
بالنسبه للسفارات وماساه بالنسبه لاصحاب
الجوازات
المقداد حسن لقناتي العربيه والحدث انظر
مات
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار برامج وال
قصص اشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات